les agresseurs du jeune supporter de
l'équipe de tel-aviv sont des membres
d'un groupe de supporters du psg baptisé
les boulogne boys réputés pour leurs
actions violentes et leur idéologie
raciste
depuis des années maintenant le psg
gangréné par la violence qui s'exprime
dans les tribunes aller à l'extérieur du
stade parfois même à l'encontre des
joueurs les dirigeants
ce matin encore d'ailleurs marc d'haene
à steve hill bromberg
les abords du parc des princes ne leur
suffisent plus ce matin leur violence
est arrivé jusqu'au camp d'entraînement
du psg depuis la mort d'un des leurs à
attiser toutes les colères ce décès est
un tournant dans leur histoire
tumultueuse
cela fait vingt ans que quelques
centaines d'individus entache l'image du
club par cette violence face à la presse
le président du psg reconnaît comme ses
prédécesseurs son impuissance
donc vous voyez ça si vous n'êtes pas un
peu costaud vous avez envie de retourner
chez vous aidez vous dire allez terminer
parce que ce que je suis entrain de foot
en tant que responsable du paris saint
germain pas un mot sur le racisme et
l'antisémitisme de certains supporters
un silence dénoncée par plusieurs
associations de lutte contre le racisme
car des comportements xénophobes de
supporters proches de l'extrême droite
défraye depuis longtemps la chronique
ses supporters pour son des jeunes sont
les jeunes des jeunes qui partagent les
sensibilités
politique ou intra politique mais du
racisme mais très vite je tends pas
honte aussi un certain goût pour la pour
la violence aujourd'hui on sait qu'à ce
stade sur deux en france est victime
d'actes par des groupuscules d'extrême
droite
pour les autres supporters parisiens la
sécurité autour des stades ne doit pas
être la seule à attirer l'attention des
médias
ce qu'il faut retenir ce soir c'est
avant tout la mort d'un jeune homme de
24 ans vont vouloir dire on va régler
les maux du football
les problèmes de violence dans le foot
il faudrait s'intéresser à la société
dans lequel on vit on vit dans une
société ultra violente
on vit dans une société où personne
n'accepte l'autre est le vrai problème
il est là régler le problème dans la
société vont règlerait le problème dans
les stades de foot les stades de foot
c'est un miroir un microcosme de la
société
aujourd'hui les associations de
supporters en france sont tout de même
des gens assez responsable et je crois
que toutes ces personnes là en france
sont prêtes à se tenir à se réunir à se
mettre autour d'une table avec les
pouvoirs publics et à discuter ce soir
les membres des associations de
supporters se sont retrouvés devant le
siège du club parisien
demain ils seront reçus par nicolas
sarkozy avec les présidents de la
fédération et de la ligue de football